I like I just [ __ ] I just bought bidets
for my bathroom at the crib
don't you do game changer bidets is the
most amazing what is a bidet costs under
$100 shut the [ __ ] up and you attach it
to your toy oh yeah yeah yeah yeah hook
up a little core and it's dope dude it's
I put them in I got them both my
bathroom so is your bday sit next to
your toilet like a sidecar on a
motorcycle or is it the same thing it's
no it's like a sock it's like a little
attachable thing it's just like a lever
that you don't owe your business and
then you move over six inches now dude
no place right yeah and it's you it's in
there it's in the toilet it's in the
toilet that lever is on a side works and
it comes out and it still it's amazing
abused toilet paper but just basically
to dry off it's yeah even to wipe the
water yeah man it's it's great you
everyone everyone
yeah the hallways the whole thing dude
if you if you if you picked up a piece
of [ __ ] right would you just put toilet
paper on it and consider your hands
clean at least want to water it off or
rinse it on ice like you're selling
bidets now I I do it I'm pro bidet
everybody should have one especially
especially if you in a relationship and
things get boring and you might eat some
ass why would you not have a bidet there
go